Ukraine's military is calling
Russia's bluff
near the strategic city of her son.
Military spokeswoman
says Russia is creating an illusion
that it's
pulling out of the city
to lure
Ukrainian forces into street fighting.
There have been indications of a possible
Russian withdrawal from her son,
but Moscow has also been sending
in reinforcements.
Meanwhile, Russia is planning
to use more hardcore criminals
to fight in the war.
President Putin has signed the law
to conscript
murderers, drug dealers and others
who were recently released from prison.
The move could potentially allow
the deployment
of hundreds of thousands of people
who are previously banned
from the military.
Now back in Ukraine, President Zelensky
says he's
not buying Iran's new claim
about supplying military drones
to Russia.
Tehran
did an about face on Friday, saying
it sent a limited number of drones
to Moscow in the months before the war.
The statement came
after weeks
of Iranian denials
that it provided any drones to Russia.
President Zelinsky says Iran's new claim
still doesn't add up to more.
Some Abdulaziz joins us from Kiev.
So some Ukraine
pushing back hard on
those drone claims by Iran.
Yeah, a
very significant
admission came from
Iran's foreign minister
to a press conference saying
that, yes,
Iran did provide a limited number
of drones to Russia.
But and this is a very big bite.
It was prior to the conflict, months
prior to this conflict,
and that Iran has no knowledge
that Russia is using those drones
here in the war on Ukraine.
Let me start by clarifying this
right away, Kim.
We do know that Iranian made drones
are being used here in Ukraine
because Ukrainian officials have found
the remnants of them
after they've struck out
apartment buildings
or terrorize citizens
and they've been able to show
those remnants to journalists as well.
Now, what was also curious
about that statement
from Iran's foreign minister was
then he went on to ask Ukraine
to provide concrete evidence.
Take a listen
to how President Zelensky responded to
all this
to Rachel Wood today.
There were messages from Iran,
from official representatives there.
They decided to admit
that they did supply drones
for Russian terror.
But even in this confession, they lied.
We shoot down at least
ten Iranian drones every day.
And if Iran continues
lying about the obvious,
it means that the world
will make even more efforts
to investigate
the terrorist cooperation
between the Russian and Iranian regimes
and what Russia is paying Iran
for such cooperation.
Is it the
now, not only has Iran provided
Russia with weapons.
Western sources say
that Tehran is preparing
to send
even more weapons
to Russia, including more drones
and ballistic missiles.
That's, of course, very crucial
to Russia.
That's used a great deal of its
arsenal here in the invasion of Ukraine.
It could help boost the fight for her
so and so.
A very curious statement there from Iran.
And a final point.
This could also have consequences
for Iran itself.
Kim, the United States, other
allies have said
they will step up sanctions
if Iran continues to support
Moscow in this fight.
And Salma.
Another story
we're following,
a Russia appointed judge
in the self-proclaimed Donetsk People's
Republic is
in serious condition
after an alleged assassination attempt.
What more can you tell us about that?
Yes, very interesting report
that came out in the evening hours
yesterday.
Russian appointed officials saying
that a Russian backed judge
in the Donetsk region
this is a Russian occupied region is now
in critical condition
after there was an assassination
attempt on him.
Now, this judge is significant.
His
he was the judge
who sentenced three foreigners
in June to death, including two
British fighters
who had been here
fighting with Ukrainian forces.
Now, Russian backed officials,
Moscow blaming Ukraine for this.
Ukraine not responding.
But this isn't the first time
we've seen this where Russian backed
officials have been attacked
in these very shadowy circumstances.
And you always get that sense, Kim,
that, yes,
we have this open war on the battlefield,
but there's also this other kind
of covert war
that happens in the shadows, Kim.
All right.
Thanks so much.
Salma Abdulaziz live in Kiev.